i recall reading in one of your
scientific american articles about the
limitations of knowing a theory of
everything and you cited girdle now i'm
not sure if you were citing girdle to
say that what girdles in completeness
theorem has to say is something about
whether or not we can ultimately find
the laws that govern us or you're using
that to say well look there are
limitations so let's be a bit more
humble which one was it does girdle
theorem have anything to do
it was the second one i think we should
be humble because
we will never have a complete theory of
everything
logically that was demonstrated by
ghetto but
but also you know the scientific
process is working progress you know we
it turns out that when we discover new
things we can ask more questions it's
not that we ask less questions so the
the illusion that you know physics would
get to an end and that would be it
you know that was uh
advocated
a hundred years ago before uh einstein
came more than a hundred years 100 yeah
20 years ago
before einstein came with special
relativity and quantum mechanics was
discovered and clearly physics was
revolutionized
and it's being it was said in recent
decades by some people and again i think
they're completely misguided because
uh you know knowledge is just an island
in an ocean of ignorance we we know so
little and
the way to for us to maintain
the integrity of science is to stay
modest and say look we we don't know so
much and and it's working progress and
sometimes we may be wrong so let's be
open-minded and let's continue to
collect evidence and and make progress
through that why does girdles in
completeness theorem have anything to do
with whether or not we can learn the
fundamental laws
because
what ghetto demonstrated is that you
cannot build a
a self-consistent
logical system that uh
that
that
can be proven uh
and and and be self-contained so to
speak i see i see you you're talking
about whether or not we can prove that
our theory of everything is the theory
of everything so there will always be
some loopholes even at the logical level
uh
but
what i'm referring to in addition to
that is the fact that
uh reality you know
it will take us a long while before we
figure out all the details of reality
through experiments in addition to the
logical issues